[Musique]
l'arme du Kremlin la Russie est-elle un
état promoteur du terrorisme et bien on
en débat avec les invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés niagai
Bagayoko bonsoir présidente de
l'africaine security secteur network
bienvenue à vous niagali en face de vous
Elsa Vidal bonsoir Elsa journaliste
rédactrice en chef de la rédaction russe
de RFI merci également d'être avec nous
Carole Valade est avec nous bonsoir
également journaliste ancien
correspondant en République
centrafricaine co-réalisateur du
documentaire pour Arte et pour France 24
Centrafrique le soft power russe un
documentaire d'ailleurs qu'on peut
toujours trouver en ligne et puis vous
avez remporté le prix pour le
journaliste de Daphné Corana gallicia un
prix qui est décerné d'ailleurs par le
Parlement européen et c'était en octobre
dernier bienvenue à vous nous avons
duplex de Strasbourg bonsoir à vous
Fabienne Keller euro député du groupe
Rignoux
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors on
va démarrer ce débat avec d'abord
Emmanuel Macron qui n'a pas prononcé le
mot Wagner ce week-end au sommet de la
Francophonie à Djerba mais il avait les
bien évoqué un etarus prédateur à
l'œuvre en Afrique on va écouter le
président français
et moi je ne suis pas du pain beaucoup
d'influenceurs y compris parfois des
gens qui sont sur vos plateaux pour
porter une voix ils sont payés par les
Russes tu le sais très bien on les
connaît et en boucle ce discours etc ils
ont jamais connu eux-mêmes la
colonisation ne savent pas ce que c'est
mais ils sont là parce que c'est un
discours politique
et parce que plusieurs puissances qui
veulent bâtir une influence en Afrique
développe cela pour abîmer la France
abîmer sa langue faire douter mais
surtout aller chercher des intérêts
suffit d'aller voir ce qui se passe en
ce moment en Centre Afrique ou ailleurs
pour voir très clairement quel est le
projet russe qui est à l'oeuvre quand la
France est bousculée c'est un projet de
prédation
prédation on parle là de sujets parfois
fragiles mais on Centrafrique on n'a pas
à se poser la question de savoir s'il y
a encore des libertés publiques si le
droit des uns et des autres n'est pas
foulé au pied c'est une réalité et il y
a avec la complicité d'une jungle
militaire russe
un peu votre spécialité en Afrique ça
fait un an que le groupe Wagner les
mercenaires Wagner sont au Mali donc il
y a eu cette ce rapport de olives en
vagues qui parle de 23 cas d'assassinat
de violation de droits humains on vient
d'écouter Emmanuel Macron qui parle donc
d'une prédation côté russe quel bilan on
peut faire déjà de la présence sur le
terrain Wagner au Mali aujourd'hui même
si les informations sont compliquées
effectivement avoir sur place alors
l'accès au terrain effectivement est
extrêmement difficile mais j'ajouterai
une troisième source qui est parue
aujourd'hui et qui va dans le sens des
autres c'est le rapport publié par la
Fédération internationale des droits de
l'homme qui met aussi en cause Wagner
cette fois-ci dans des viols qui
seraient survenus dans le centre du Mali
au printemps dernier donc au delà de ce
bilan dramatique en matière de droit de
l'homme et de des actions commises on
s'aperçoit que sur le terrain la ful
reconquête qui était annoncées notamment
par les autorités maliennes qui je le
rappelle n'ont toujours pas reconnu la
présence de Wagner n'a absolument pas eu
lieu on a vu au contraire
on a vu au contraire une aggravation de
la situation et une expansion de ces
groupes en revanche dans le domaine de
la guerre informationnelle cette
présence est extrêmement visible et
extrêmement efficace parce qu'en fait il
y a donc un volet terrain militaire
contre de lutte contre toi et
djihadistes et puis un volet
informationnel Carole Valade alors vous
vous avez fait un documentaire sur
Wagner en République centrafricaine
avant d'être au Mali ils étaient en RCA
donc c'était vraiment le précédent de
Wagner on va voir j'espère les images de
votre documentaire où on voit justement
des habitants de Centrafrique qui qui
portent ces t-shirts Wagner Poutine donc
est-ce qu'ils opèrent de la même façon
en Centrafrique komalie ou plutôt est-ce
que Mali les opère comme en Centrafrique
si on prend les choses dans l'ordre
alors c'est vrai qu'on a retrouvé des
éléments semblables et ça a été frappant
pour ceux qui ont suivi le développement
des activités de Wagner en République
centrafricaine de retrouver des des
schémas des choses qui ont été faits de
la de la même façon après c'est assez
différent parce qu'elles ont été mises
en place de façon beaucoup plus rapide
au Mali ça fait vraiment simplement en
quelques en quelques mois alors
concentré qui a eu tout un travail qui a
pris des années quatre ans en fait
puisqu'ils sont arrivés en 2018 de mise
en place d'installations de pénétration
des des centres de pouvoir et donc ça
fait quand même beaucoup plus longtemps
mais on retrouve quand même ce qui est
en tout cas le plus le plus marquant et
le plus le plus grave les exactions les
viols les pillages et tous les crimes de
guerre qui sont commis sur le terrain et
qui ont été déjà depuis des années en
Centrafrique documenté en grande partie
notamment par les Nations Unies et il a
des informations également et la
désinformation parce que c'est un des
piliers fondamentaux on dit souvent
qu'il y a trois piliers fondamentaux
dans l'action de Wagner qui sont d'abord
par ça reste une société militaire
privée donc d'abord des services de
sécurité qui sont payés qui sont fournis
à des états ou à des ou à des compagnies
ensuite il y a les activités extractives
parce que souvent des états comme la
centrale ou le Mali sont pas forcément
mesures de payer suffisamment donc il y
a des contrats miniers qui sont qui sont
accordés en échange de ses services et
enfin il y a le volet information
stratégique communication et propagande
qui fait l'objet du documentaire qu'on a
réalisé avec Clément di Roma et qui a
pas négligé parce que c'est quelque part
là où il y a des impacts plus une des
plus grandes réussites en fait parce
qu'avec très peu de moyens dans des pays
où c'est assez facile parce que dans des
dans des états faibles ou avec ou des ou
des pays pauvres c'est beaucoup plus
facile de développer une la propagande
justement à faible coût mais avec un
impact médiatique et un impact sur les
sur les consciences qui va être très
fort fake news donc Elsa Vidal vous qui
êtes la spécialiste Russie
Ukraine ils sont ils ont démarré en fait
en Ukraine il faut le dire Wagner ou pas
exactement peut-être Libye avant mais en
tout cas en 2014 lors de la guerre dans
le bon basque on parlait déjà de de
Wagner de ces mercenaires est-ce que
justement aujourd'hui on reparle
beaucoup d'ailleurs de Wagner parce que
il y a cette guerre en Ukraine est-ce
que les moyens d'action sont différents
justement en Ukraine et en Afrique où
est-ce que on est très proche mais de
mode opératoire on est assez proche
parce que comme vous l'avez dit Wagner
c'est d'abord une compagnie qui doit
dégager de l'argent et qui doit se
nourrir sur la bête donc partout Wagner
est présent il y a un mélange de
recherche effectivement de gains
immédiatement convertibles généralement
ils ne sont pas beaucoup payés donc ils
doivent trouver ressources dans les dans
les terrains où ils sont envoyés
dont ils ont la gestion tous les
pillages tous les pillages d'où les
violences doux aussi les appropriations
ils sont également connus effectivement
pour opérer de manière discrète la
plupart du temps sans être
reconnaissable dans un climat de
dénégation ce qui a changé en fait c'est
que depuis septembre on sait
qu'officiellement la responsabilité des
activités de ce groupe a été reconnue et
endossés par leur fondateurs et
dirigeants et gagner prigogène mais
jusque là il s'agissait toujours d'un
nuage de flou qui flottait alors que si
on analysait en quelque sorte à qui
profiter la présence des Wagner on avait
compris dans quelle direction pointer le
radar mais on ne pouvait pas absolument
enfin l'exécutif
de toute façon
en Syrie que ce soit en Libye que ce
soit en Ukraine avec la volonté de
terroriser ce contre qui ils sont
envoyés combattre donc avec ce qu'on a
vu très récemment la vidéo qui était
très choquant d'un assassinat avec une
masse d'un homme de Wagner qui serait
passé côté ukrainien on a connu des
précédents en Syrie avec un partisan de
l'Armée syrienne libre si je ne me
trompe pas qui avait été martyrisé
devant une caméra à des fins d'une part
de montrer que les missions sont
remplies et que il s'agit de se battre
contre la terreur quand on se bat contre
Wagner et c'est pour ça qu'il est
toujours très difficile finalement de
couvrir les activités de Wagner parce
que ce faisant on leur fait de la
promotion donc attention bien sûr il
faut le faire avec
parcimonie attention un texte en tout
cas était voté par le Parlement européen
hier je le disais qualifiant la Russie
d'étapes promoteurs du terrorisme et qui
utilise donc des moyens terroristes le
site internet d'ailleurs du Parlement
européen juste après ce vote a été
l'objet d'une cyberattaque revendiquée
par un groupe procremlin c'était
quelques heures après le vote on va
d'abord écouter la réaction de
volodimeers alinski le président
ukrainien après le vote de ce texte par
le Parlement européen
aujourd'hui le Parlement européen a
finalement reconnu la Russie comme un
état soutenant le terrorisme merci à
tous les parlementaires et puis la
Russie a prouvé que c'était vrai en
lançant 67 missiles sur nos
imprastructures sur notre secteur
énergétique sur les gens ordinaires
Fabienne Keller vous êtes avec toi en
direct de Strasbourg cette résolution en
fait elle a une portée symbolique mais
finalement vous allez encore plus loin
qu'Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il parle
d'État prédateur en disant que c'est un
état terroriste alors vous nommez pas
Wagner précisément me semble-t-il dans
le texte mais quelque part que lorsque
vous parlez de moyens terroriste utilisé
par les tarus est-ce que vous incluez
Wagner
oui bien sûr c'est Wagner qui est ciblé
mais peut-être d'autres
groupuscules qui pourraient être
soutenus par par la Russie mais nous
avons pris une résolution c'est à dire
un texte très politique
pour reconnaître que la Russie est un
état soutenant le terrorisme et les
moyens utilisés par le terrorisme nous
appelons aussi l'Union européenne et en
particulier le Conseil européen à se
doter d'un outil juridique qui
permettrait des sanctions de ce fait
puisque les États-Unis peuvent
reconnaître le statut de soutien au
terrorisme mais nous n'avons pas la
l'arsenal juridique et puis l'idée
évidemment c'est de marquer
politiquement que nous nous n'acceptons
pas enfin nous nous dressons contre ces
méthodes tout à fait inacceptables cette
manière de faire la guerre aujourd'hui
en Ukraine mais aussi d'être présent au
Mali vous l'évoquiez avec des exactions
des violences inouïes donc le Parlement
a une très large majorité plus de 480
voix il y avait peut-être 494 d'après ce
que j'ai lu contre donc une très grande
voilà 494 pardon 58 comptes j'ai les
chiffres devant moi 44 abstention vous
voyez une très très large majorité il y
avait guère que des RN français pro
russe pour refuser de voter une telle
résolution donc qui est très importante
vous l'avez dit elle a été suivie par
une cyber-attaque contre le site du
Parlement qui permettait en fait à tout
le monde de suivre justement nos débats
mais bon le Parlement est protégé nous
avons pu continuer nos travaux une
cyberattaque donc d'un groupe procrément
revendiquer Fabienne Keller juste une
question encore sur ce terrorisme se
qualificatif puisqu'en fait vous parliez
des États-Unis mais les États-Unis vont
absolument pas aussi loin ils ne parlent
pas de terrorisme et il y a en fait il
me semble qu'il y a que trois états les
trois États baltes qui ont fait parlent
de de ont voté des résolutions
similaires parce qu'en fait on dit que
peut être un frein si on veut s'engager
justement dans des négociations et qu'on
se lit un peu les mains en qualifiant
cet état de terroriste
nous faisons le choix clair et à une
large très très large majorité d'être
aux côtés des Ukrainiens dans cette
guerre qui a déclenché Vladimir Poutine
il commet par le biais notamment de
Wagner des actes de terreur vous
l'évoquez vos personnalités présentes
sur le plateau les cités c'est tout à
fait inadmissible l'Europe porte des
valeurs elle est donc au con aux côtés
de ceux qui se battent contre la Russie
et nous la dénonçons avec tous les
outils qui sont les nôtres c'est pour
cela que nous avons avec à partir d'un
texte rédigé par la coalition centrale
au Parlement pu faire avoir un large
soutien large consensus sur cette
volonté oui de condamner fermement la
Russie et cette ces actes de terreur
qu'il soutiennent en Ukraine un mot
peut-être sur ce qualificatif de
terrorisme alors la difficulté sur un
terrain africain c'est sans doute la
conf qui risque de s'introduire entre
les différents acteurs le terme de
terroristes et généralement appliqué au
Mali en l'occurrence à des groupes
djihadistes qui se livrent à des actes
d'insurrection et effectivement pour
certains d'entre eux d'instimisation de
massacres de ces populations de plus un
certain nombre d'années en revanche le
groupe Wagner intervient aux côtés des
forces armées maliennes donc ceux qui
risquent d'introduire une certaine
confusion parmi les populations c'est de
voir que des deux côtés ont qualifie les
protagonistes en utilisant le même terme
et je compléterai en disant que on
parlait de l'accès aux ressources de la
prédation aujourd'hui il y a notamment
des pillages qui se font sur le bétail
qui est la principale source de revenus
de ces populations en lien avec des
milices d'autodé qui sont elles-mêmes
difficiles à qualifier donc il faut
faire très attention à ne pas introduire
trop de confusion entre les différents
acteurs Carole c'est exactement la même
chose en République centrafricaine ou
Wagner intervient en appui de l'armée de
l'armée nationale et combat des groupes
armés qui sont qualifiés de terroristes
par le gouvernement donc on a aussi
exactement la même la même situation
elle intervient dans un effort pour à la
fois disqualifié politiquement l'action
de la Russie en dehors de ses frontières
dès lors qu'elle recourt à la violence à
la violence illégale ce qui est le cas
en Ukraine ce qui est le cas dans
d'autres terrains également mais cette
opposition ou cette confusion n'est pas
la même disons que dans l'espace
européen ou occidental c'est plutôt pour
porter le fer dans le fait que la Russie
alors qu'elle est un état qu'elle est
dotée aussi d'une armée et qu'elle
pourrait recourir à des actions qui
s'inscrivent dans le droit international
choisit délibérément de son éc et de
recourir à ce qu'on voit d'habitude être
larmes un peu des états faibles ou des
mouvements d'insurrection c'est à dire
les attaques cyber terroristes
c'est-à-dire le recours aux factions
armées privées au mercenaires puisque
c'est le terme qui sont d'ailleurs
interdits en Russie malgré le réellement
officiellement et ce qui est intéressant
parce que c'est introduit aussi le
mépris où ça vient éclairé le mépris des
autorités russes actuelles vis-à-vis de
la loi et de la Constitution russe
qu'elles avaient pourtant en un temps
promu pour rétablir la verticale de
l'État donc on voit à quel point on
s'est éloigné de cette période du régime
de Vladimir Poutine pour entrer dans un
état assez indéfini chaotique et très
difficile à prévoir à Fabienne Keller je
sais que au Parlement européen on parle
beaucoup de cette guerre
informationnelle justement et puis cette
arme de Vladimir Poutine de la
propagande et d'utilisation justement
par Wagner on vient d'en parler sur ce
plateau de moyen de propagande il y a
notamment cet appui à formationnel qui
s'appelle le ria fan alors j'espère que
je le prononce bien parce que ça fait
partie du rapport justement de l'IRCEM
sur la question qui incite étendard de
la holding médiatique de Prigogine donc
le prix gaugine patriote et là ce rien
de fan a un pouvoir manifestement en
Afrique extrêmement fort
bien sûr la désinformation
l'ingérence par le biais de fausses
informations les fake news nous nous
préoccupe une commission spéciale a été
créée il y a deux ans maintenant elle
devait être temporaire elle poursuit ses
travaux c'est évidemment un pouvoir très
très important vous vous souvenez que
même en France jusqu'à la guerre
déclenchée par la Russie à l'égard de
l'Ukraine ont laissé diffuser rachat
today qui était un outil de propagande
on le savait bien donc cette
désinformation elle est encore plus
présente en Afrique ou probablement les
gens ont moins accès à une diversité de
canaux d'où l'importance d'ailleurs de
canaux comme les vôtres qui offrent une
autre information d'autres sources pour
qu'ils puissent eux-mêmes se faire leur
opinion mais évidemment c'est un outil
extrêmement utilisé par par les Russes
on voit combien d'ailleurs les exactions
même du groupe Wagner en Ukraine
manipulées par eux accusant l'Ukraine
d'en être à l'origine donc il faut être
extrêmement vigilant chaque fois qu'on
découvre une information sur les réseaux
sociaux sur différentes chaînes
d'information qui pourraient venir de
Russie
quelque chose vous ce fameux si étendard
de cette fameuse holding parce que
Prigogine on va en parler un peu plus de
ce personnage et bien il a créé une
holding médiatique me dit-on enfin en
tout cas c'est ce que j'ai lu Prigogine
patriote d'ailleurs on appelle ça et qui
sert justement à diffuser cette
propagande et l'impact extra fort mais
justement ça renvoie à ce statut
juridique extrêmement flou et très
plastique qui échappe à la plupart des
définitions que soient celles de
définition du mercenaria selon les
termes juridiques internationaux que ce
soit celle de société militaire privée y
compris en droit rue interne et qui fait
que aujourd'hui ce qui a été créé c'est
une société de communication et de
recherche pour couvrir l'ensemble de ces
activités y compris militaires donc de
ce point de vue de galaxies en fait pas
du tout dans un terme qu'emploie les
chercheurs notamment ce que vous vous
situiez et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que au-delà de ce rien fan
effectivement de ce site il y a
différents moyens de communication alors
vous citiez les médias d'État Sputnik et
rue chativi mais vous avez bien
évidemment les usines à trolls sur les
réseaux sociaux qui sont très efficaces
notamment parce qu'elles utilisent des
acteurs locaux mais vous avez par
exemple en RCA des radios entières comme
un goût Sango qui ce qui sont aux mains
des des Russes en réalité et qui
diffusent des informations qui d'une
part leur sont favorables et qui
cherchent aussi à miner l'indépendance
d'autres enfin l'indépendance et la
réputation d'autres acteurs on serait
Carl on se demande comment ils ont
réussi tout de même à mettre tous
dispositifs en place en si peu de temps
avec finalement pas tant d'hommes que ça
avec fin on a l'impression quand même
l'impact extrêmement fort vraiment
stratégique du groupe Wagner ou mieux
dit comme Lady de la galaxie parce qu'en
fait ce qu'on appelle Wagner c'est plein
d'entreprises plein de personnes
différentes avec des intérêts différents
et plein de spécialisations différentes
mais ce qu'on considère et comme Wagner
et donc la galaxie Wagner
sa principale réussite c'est ça c'est de
avec très peu de moyens finalement très
peu d'hommes à faire un avoir un impact
vraiment disproportionné
et en faveur on la faveur de la Russie
en fait ça a pris du temps quand même ça
a été c'est à dire que ça ils sont
arrivés donc en 2018 donc il y a eu
plusieurs années pour pour mettre en
place pour faire ce travail de la
complicité des politiques comme ça que
ça se passe pour s'installer c'est un
accord avec le gouvernement en
donnant des services de sécurité en
échange de cette de cette installation
et c'est quelque chose donc appris qui a
pris du temps à mettre en place et qui a
été fait aussi parce que c'est un pays
très pauvre parce que c'est un état
faible et que ça coûtait pas grand chose
finalement à faire en République
centrafricaine c'était assez simple
ce que j'aimerais souligner c'est que
effectivement Wagner a une capacité de
progression très très rapide dans des
sociétés où il y a assez peu d'offres
concurrentielles où il y a aussi des
crises des crises et puis tout
simplement du clientélisme il faut pas
non plus penser que les populations
locales sont acquises à Wagner qu'il
s'agit d'un gain durable pour la Russie
il va falloir je pense surveiller la
situation sur un temps moyen ou sur un
temps beaucoup plus long on n'est pas
dans des logiques d'ancrage durable on
est plutôt effectivement dans des
logiques d'appropriation rapide
d'enrichissement rapide qui puisse être
utile ensuite à l'État russe peut-être
[Musique]
en termes en tout cas d'efficacité
militaire ça n'a pris nulle part
finalement
parce que ça n'a pas pris en Libye ça
n'a pas pris vraiment au Soudan ni aux
Mozambique à Madagascar le qui a été
différent parce que on parlait
d'investissement dans la campagne
électorale on peut considérer qu'il y a
eu un certain succès mais quand même on
ne peut pas dire qu'il y ait des succès
fulgurants mais ce qui est important
c'est encore une fois pour revenir avec
sur ces liens avec les targues c'est
aussi que ce succès à mon avis il
provient du fait que il y a une
réactivation des techniques de
propagande et du discours impérialiste
qui a eu cours pendant 30 années après
les indépendances qui à la faveur de la
chute du mur de Berlin a connu un reflux
mais il ne faut pas croire qu'on assiste
à l'utilisation de méthodes entièrement
nouvelle ça c'est un élément qui me
paraît extrêmement important et c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il y a cette efficacité
absolument c'est un savoir qui est un
peu nouveau je voulais vous poser la
question Fabienne Keller c'est-à-dire
quelque chose de quand même d'assez
global on parle d'acteurs non étatique
qui ont un rôle important à la fois d'un
point sur militaire mais aussi
informationsnel on parle de guerre
hybride c'est vrai que c'est pas très
nouveau mais enfin bon c'est quelque
chose quand même je dirais presque
nouveau pour les politiques de l'Europe
de l'Union européenne
bien sûr pour protéger nos valeurs il
faut savoir se faire respecter par
rapport à des états et cette nouvelle
forme d'action politique au plus près
des populations nécessite pour nous des
nouveaux outils c'est pour ça que nous
nous y travaillons nous je vous disais
qu'une commission spécifique a été
structurée pour cela et c'est pour ça
que nous proposons aussi que des outils
juridiques à l'égard de groupuscules
armés je crois d'ailleurs que le groupe
Wagner est cité dans notre résolution
soit constitué par l'Union européenne
pour qu'on puisse les identifier et
prendre des sanctions à leur à leur
égard
l'idée est aussi peut-être de réfléchir
à un arsenal juridique qui permettrait
de les poursuivre puisque pour l'instant
on s'est poursuivre des états on s'est
poursuivre des individus mais on ne sait
pas
poursuivre des groupuscules armés donc
c'est se doter d'outils efficace pour
préserver pour protéger l'Union
européenne
et faire respecter aussi
ça me permet difficile mais le droit de
la guerre qui là n'est pas respecté par
l'utilisation de ces factions
terroristes peut-être ça la nouveauté
Elsa effectivement cette réactivité fin
obligatoire aujourd'hui des pays
européens face à une nouvelle de
nouveaux ennemis entre guillemets alors
ils sont nouveaux uniquement parce que
notre mémoire est un peu courte c'est
normal dans la vie d'un être humain on
n'a pas nécessairement le retour sur 80
ou 70 ans mais les techniques qu'on voit
à l'oeuvre en Afrique et aussi en Europe
et aux États-Unis puisque je rappelle
qu'ils gagné Prigogine a aussi endossé
la responsabilité de l'ingérence dans
les élections américaines précédentes il
l'a revendiqué tout en disant qu'il le
referait ce sont des techniques
absolument classiques de l'Union
soviétique classique du mouvement
bolchevique et on avait vu en 1937 si je
me trompe pas aussi ce qu'on appelle des
actions des actions de déstabilisation
sous fausses bannière qui consistait par
exemple à créer des mouvements
d'opposition en Europe des mouvements
d'opposition à l'Union soviétique qui
fédérer les opposants ensuite on savait
où trouver les opposants on pouvait les
infiltrer puis les retourner ou les
faire chanter ou les assassiner donc
toutes ces techniques de déstabilisation
elles elles participent à l'arsenal de
la guerre entre les États c'est une
vision ou les États n'ont que des
intérêts rivalisent entre eux c'est une
vision qui est assez intéressante aussi
pour comprendre le monde actuel même si
l'Europe essaye de construire une
citadelle dans laquelle nous vivons en
paix sans rivalité entre état alors on
va revenir sur yu-geney prigogi tout de
même ce personnage et puis c'est liens
avec Vladimir Poutine on parle on a
parlé de la galaxie Prigogine c'est un
ancien criminel ou gagner Prigogine
transformé en homme d'affaires russes
patrons d'abord d'une chaîne de
restaurant on la surnommé le cuisinier
de Poutine un homme de Londres ou le
traiteur de Poutine et c'est un homme de
l'ombre de plus en plus dans la lumière
on va écouter un journaliste russe qui
justement parle de lui
il est probablement le seul en Russie
actuellement qui parle ouvertement avec
une rhétorique patriotique qui n'hésite
pas à dire qu'il donne son argent
personnel à l'opération spéciale et à
divers projets
quels sont les liens vraiment déjà entre
Vladimir Poutine et pris goji frigoji
finalement on dit pas que c'est un
oligarque on dit que c'est un
entrepreneur c'est le terme qui revient
le plus c'est une politique Tatiana
stanovaillac et a utilisé cette
terminologie et c'est vrai que ça décrit
assez bien les logiques à l'oeuvre mais
c'est dans un environnement politique
très particulier donc c'est pas juste un
chef d'entreprise c'est un chef
d'entreprise d'abord c'est un survivant
qui vient de Saint-Pétersbourg c'est un
homme qui a traversé l'effondrement de
l'État soviétique et qui s'est lancé
dans des années de grands chaos dans des
activités criminelles il a été puni pour
ça il a fait 9 ans de prison il tire
beaucoup de fierté en fait de son passé
de bandit de zec en fait ça veut dire de
prisonniers parce que il construit
l'idée contestataire de l'opposition
d'un seul homme à l'état les hommes les
plus forts qui dominent dans la pyramide
sociale il est devenu proche de Vladimir
Poutine mais progressivement en fait par
les services qu'il a mis en œuvre et en
fait quand on dit le cuisinier de
Poutine il a véritablement sa fortune en
étant en fait le traiteur de l'armée et
du ministère de la Défense et puis il a
diversifié ses activités quand on parle
d'entrepreneur ce qu'on veut dire par là
c'est que une fois qu'il a eu gagné la
confiance du chef du Kremlin on lui
donne un territoire qu'il est en liberté
en droit d'exploiter la contrepartie
c'est qu'il met à disposition du Kremlin
toutes les ressources qu'on lui
demandera au moment où on les lui
demandera et en ce moment le chef du
Kremlin est un peu à la peine à la
difficulté il mène une guerre il faut
donc fournir des hommes du sang de
l'argent et c'est ce que Prigogine fait
et c'est ce qui fait tout en prenant un
peu son indépendance en ce moment on a
l'impression mais on va y revenir je
voudrais que vous rebondissiez peut-être
niagali sur justement les liens entre
Poutine et Prigogine et est-ce que
Prigogine ce nom même est connu au Mali
dans ces pays d'Afrique on parle de
priscogie on ne parle que de Poutine des
liens entre les deux alors il est de
plus en plus connu parce que non
seulement il a cette image de patriote
mais il cherche à développer une image
d'anti impérialiste c'est un discours
qu'il tient de manière de plus en plus
ouverte depuis quelques mois depuis
qu'il assume en fait son rôle et il
l'appelle très explicitement les
populations africaines à s'inscrire en
fausse si ce n'est à s'insurger contre
les anciennes puissances coloniales
pendant longtemps on avait des
certitudes mais non démontré la présence
était avérée mais très difficile à
démontrer maintenant elle est elle est
assumée de de ce point de vue là mais là
où il me semble y avoir une véritable
caisse de résonance et une véritable
effet c'est que à l'inverse de tous les
instruments caissés de développer les
Européens leur capacité à Wagner et à la
Russie c'est de faire parler les
opinions publiques ou les réseaux
sociaux en leur nom c'est une grande
différence c'est à dire qu'on va bien
au-delà des seuls condamnations
diplomatique ou politique ou
institutionnels on voit des
manifestations massives qui brandissent
le drapeau de la Russie et qui donc
presque
inutile l'intervention directe et
verbale de prix gojin ou de Poutine
votre expérience vous renverser à y
parlait de on a vu ces t-shirts Poutine
Russie est-ce que on parle de privilégie
aussi
ça commence un petit peu mais c'est
encore très enfin c'est pas encore très
important peut-être juste avant un petit
bémol sur l'absence que vous avez évoqué
de victoire militaires de Wagner sur le
terrain c'est différent
c'est-à-dire que
centrafricaines ça marche mieux d'un
point de vue militaire
qui est et ça c'est indéniable et on
peut pas le on peut pas dire le
contraire c'est que au moment en janvier
2021 lorsque les groupes armés se sont
coalisés pour fondre sur la capitale et
prendre le pouvoir les combattants
russes ont joué un rôle décisif dans la
défense de la capitale et dans toute
l'opération de reconquête qui a été
menée ensuite dans l’intérieur du pays
et évidemment ensuite Wagner a réussi à
capitaliser sur cette sur cette réussite
au moyen pour faire voilà c'est ça et
pour faire de la Centrafrique un peu
sont sa vitrine de qu'elle va pouvoir
pour en fait pour ce modèle là qu'elle
propose c'est pour l'exporter ensuite
vers d'autres pays comme comme le Mali
ou comme ou donc ça marche moins bien
c'est ce que disait selon les premiers
rapports salaires plus plus difficile
oui ensuite sur sur la sur les sur les
manifestations sur sur la propagande
alors il y a effectivement le problème
ça serait de voir ça uniquement comme on
a tendance à le voir du côté des
autorités françaises comme un pur
produit de de l'un de l'ingérence russe
et
ça serait ça serait dommage parce que ça
serait ne pas voir aussi le terreau
fertile et toutes les causes profondes
sur lesquelles ont su capitaliser les
les jantes Wagner les gens enfin
finalement il y a pas eu grand chose à
faire parce que le sentiment
anti-français ce qu'on appelle comme ça
ici il existait déjà avant que il y ait
les Russes qui arrivent et il suffisait
vraiment de pas grand chose pour pour en
faire des manifestations parce que on
Centrafrique et dans plein de pays il y
a une immense déception
vis-à-vis de de la France en particulier
de l'Occident en général qui est dû
aussi à des années de de coopération
d'aide au développement qui ont qui sont
pas est venu à sortir complètement des
pays de la pauvreté à des interventions
militaires qui sont pas parvenus en RCA
comme au Mali à mettre un terme total à
aux affrontements avec des avec des
groupes armées donc voilà c'est il faut
faire t-il bien sûr pour l'installation
de toute cette nébuleuse dont on parlait
Fabienne qu'elle est ce que vous parlez
justement au Parlement européen en
particulier de yuginny pris gojin le
fameux entrepreneur chef de Wagner il y
a des sanctions contre lui qui ont été
prises me semble-t-il par le Parlement
européen
oui nous dénonçons Wagner nous avons
déjà pris des résolutions contre ce
groupe armé bien identifié vous avez
rappelé plusieurs exemples il y a en
Ukraine on le voit agir mais on connaît
depuis 2014 on connaissait ses activités
mais nos collègues par exemple des pays
baltes sont extrêmement mobilisés sur
sur ce sujet ma collègue Nathalie
Loiseau donc oui nous dénonçons nous
essayons de mieux comprendre de
mobiliser tous les diplomates à la fois
européens et de l'ensemble des États
membres mais nous voyons bien cette
puissance qu'il a aussi cette capacité
par la désinformation et l'action mêlée
à retourner les opinions et à
aider en tout cas
on a l'impression un peu que les
Européens sont un peu désarmés ou un peu
impuissants enfin peut-être qu'ils vont
pas assez vite face à cette nébule dont
on parle
alors l'Europe est dans une situation
particulière puisqu'elle ne fait pas
elle-même la guerre directement mais
elle voit sur le territoire d'un pays
ami qu'elle soutient dans son combat
l'Ukraine ce groupe armé Wagner naître
en difficulté l'état
ukrainien donc nous ne pouvons pas agir
directement avec des forces armées nous
ne le souhaitons pas d'ailleurs nous ne
voulons pas rentrer dans ce conflit
évidemment qui deviendrait un conflit
planétaire donc
c'est une position qui n'est pas simple
la fragilité de notre position dans le
même temps enfin les attaques directes
de Wagner au Mali le retrait de nos
troupes qui s'est passé dans des
conditions que vous avez rappelé qui
sont pas bonnes alors même que nous
venions en soutien mais bon Wagner à
attaquer de la même manière la minusma
la force de l'ONU qui était là pour
assurer assurer la paix enfin leur
volonté de prendre le contrôle du du
Mali même si il n'y arrive pas
complètement
voilà montre la difficulté de de la
chose c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous
demandons qu'on crée un arsenal
juridique pour pouvoir les condamner
mais nous ne pouvons pas aller sur le
terrain directement contre eux Elsa
rapport entre Prigogine et Poutine si
Poutine ton mais est-ce que Prigogine
tombe avec lui c'est fort probable oui
que pris goji ne survive pas durablement
en tout cas pas avec la même exposition
il devra en tout cas reconstruire la
relation de confiance avec le leader qui
succéderait à Vladimir Poutine en
revanche à l'heure actuelle ce qu'on
voit c'est plutôt l'évolution de
devganisprudine d'entrepreneurs de
violence plutôt dans l'ombre à acteurs
politiques on parle de lui comme futur
président d'un parti à venir qui serait
dit qu'il voulait créer un parti
exactement qui viendrait
occuper la place les ses vacances par
par girinovski qui est décédé récemment
et qui jusque là était finalement
étendard du discours national agressif
et Prigogine en ce moment a fait part de
cette volonté politique on se demande
d'ailleurs si c'est pas la volonté de
Vladimir Poutine de l'impliquer plus
avant dans le régime au sens où il n'y
aura pas de possibilités de revenir en
arrière après une fois qu'il se sera mis
autant en avance en ayant reconnu des
crimes et en ayant maintenant
probablement un rôle politique à jouer
pour resserrer et pour resserrer les
rangs dans le régime politique c'est
vrai que il a dit qu'il allait en ce
moment il est en train de recruter dans
les prisons pour justement recruter des
mercenaires pour aller en Ukraine est-ce
que en Afrique on a l'impression qu'il
voit peut-être retirer des troupes
d'Afrique et les envoyer en Ukraine
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une sorte de des
vases communicants alors c'est ce qui a
été supposé à un moment donné pour
l'instant il ne semble pas que ce soit
le cas mais là aussi vous aviez tout à
fait raison de souligner la différence
entre les différents terrains outre le
fait qu'il y a eu effectivement cette
victoire en 2021 il faut le souligner
avec une incertitude quand aux
différents acteurs parce que la minusca
la mission des Nations Unies c'est aussi
trouver impliqué de manière un peu
compliquée par rapport à son à son
statut vis-à-vis de ses forces russes en
minuscule
en RCA il y a aussi le République
centrafricaine pardon il y a ce rôle de
vigie de protection directe du régime on
voit les membres de Wagner présent à
Bangui etc ce n'est pas le cas au Mali
au Mali le régime continue à veiller à
assurer lui-même sa propre sécurité on
n'est pas certain d'une concilier une
confiance totale non plus avec cet
acteur là de la même façon l'accès aux
mines au Mali n'a pas pu être consacré
jusqu'ici apparemment puisque les mines
sont actuellement exploitées par des
sociétés canadiennes et australienne il
ne le pape pour l'instant en tout cas
que le concret le contrat était conclu
donc ce rôle de Wagner et de trigogine
n'est pas forcément aussi facile que ça
à asseoir la RCA étant quand même un
état qui se caractérise par un grand
vide et par une absence de contrôle de
territoire historique ou là donc ça a
été un succès on peut dire la RCA c'est
le succès de Wagner en un mot est-ce que
vous avez entendu dire vous aussi que il
y aurait peut-être des retraits d'un
certain nombre de mercenaires d'Afrique
pour les envoyer en Ukraine alors très
difficile à vérifier évidemment même en
étant sur le terrain néanmoins on a
ressenti oui une si ce n'est pas une
réorganisation en tout cas une baisse
d'intensité des activités et surtout des
activités civiles de communication et de
et de stratégie maintenant ce qui est ce
qu'il faut ce qui est important de
retenir tout ça aussi c'est que
Wagner Prigogine sont pas uniquement le
bras armé du du Kreml rappelez voilà que
c'est une société que c'est une personne
qui a aussi son propre agenda et qui
peuvent avoir leur propre intérêt qui
parfois rejoignent ceux du Kremlin mais
qui peuvent aussi des fois sont donc en
ce moment il a plutôt des velléités
d'indépendance
parce qu'il doit rendre les services
pour lesquels on lui a donné cette
capacité à être le leader des Wagner il
est temps aujourd'hui qu'il rentre des
services au régime il défend aussi le
régime face aux militaires qu'il
attaquent régulièrement et qui l'accuse
de faillite donc il est là pour défendre
son maître la main qui le nourrit et de
prendre son projet politique et si le
maître venait à être affaibli alors il
serait en bonne position pour avancer
des cartes et peut-être servir un autre
maître de la pensée comme chef d'un
futur régime véritablement pour moi il y
aura un bon dans l'inconnu mais
j'aimerais dire une chose c'est qu'on
parle de Wagner mais en fait ce n'est
pas la seule compagnie de violence
privée en Russie il y en a plusieurs
autres il y en a plusieurs autres qui
ont opinion sur rue et qui elle aussi
même des activités dans des zones de
grands disparaissaient de toute façon il
y en aurait d'autres c'est un peu ça
vous avez l'air d'être d'accord je vous
entends en commentaire
oui je suis d'accord nous nous avons
pris dans oui bien sûr et dans la
délibération nous avons demandé que l'on
puisse qu'on se donne des outils pour
poursuivre et condamner non seulement
Wagner mais aussi les autres groupes qui
se constituent moi je suis une certaine
manière plus prudente que vous moi j'ai
quand même le sentiment en tout cas en
Ukraine que l'action du groupe Wagner se
fait clairement en accord avec la Russie
en appui avec la stratégie russe c'est
en tout cas ce qu'on constate sur le sur
le terrain comme Monsieur Prigogine
après peut-être des aspirations qui le
conduisent à positionner autrement par
rapport à Vladimir Poutine peut-être
mais je ne sais pas si ce n'est pas un
souhait de notre part d'une certaine
manière qui soit en rivalité aujourd'hui
ils agissent dans le même sens contre
l'Ukraine et ils font guerre aux
populations ils tuent les populations et
ils leur font subir des sévices dans le
même idée de les affaiblir et de les
battre merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
avec nous à Fabienne Keller en direct de
stras Strasbourg merci beaucoup niagalé
merci
merci Carole pardon merci à Elsa Vidal
et Merci à VOUS Carole j'ai oublié votre
nom de famille pardonnez-moi voilà merci
Carole Valade d'avoir été avec nous et
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
vous restez avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]